und jetzt
heute journal mit gundula gause und
christian sievers
hallo an einem heißen abend in
deutschland dass es im juli mal heiß
werden kann ist wetter dass es im juli
extrem häufig extrem heiß wird gibt
anlass zu großer sorge und sollte anlass
sein für größte anstrengungen die
klimakrise lässt sich nicht verdrängen
nicht durch sonntagsreden nicht durch
andere nachrichten ereignisse tatsache
ist aber die weltmacht aktuell einen
schritt vor und zwei zurück
plötzlich ist kohle wieder essentiell
bei uns die deutsche bahn steckt fest
und zwar bereits weit vor erreichen
ihres
systemrelevanten klima rettungs ziels
der bahnchef ist gleich bei uns zu gast
im studio
deutschland ist also nicht gerade
vorreiter und hat dabei aktuell die welt
zu gast weil die nächste
weltklimakonferenz
vorzubereiten ist simon pfanzelt
das meer wird ihm immer fremder erzählt
aziz lassen er ist fischer hier an der
ägyptischen nordküste jedes jahr werde
es schlimmer stürme sintflutartige regen
überflutungen
wenn ich morgens zur arbeit raus fuhr
war die straße voller wasser also musste
ich zurück und ich konnte nicht arbeiten
alle fischer sind vom klimawandel
betroffen er reduziert unsere einkommen
wie menschen wie asis la schien geholfen
werden kann darum ging es heute in
berlin petersberger klimadialog rund 40
nationen bereiten die nächste
weltklimakonferenz vor der ägyptische
präsident wird gastgeber seinem november
und erinnert daran dass afrika am
heftigsten vom klimawandel betroffen sei
die jüngsten nahrungsmittel und energie
krisen haben die herausforderungen
verschärft mit denen wir konfrontiert
sind und das noch zusätzlich zu der
realen bedrohung die der klimawandel für
uns darstellt also verwüstung
wasserknappheit der steigende
meeresspiegel
der ukraine krieg hat die klimapolitik
zurückgeworfen die welt erlebt eine
renaissance der kohle
auch in deutschland werden kraftwerke
reaktiviert das ziel bis 20.45
klimaneutral zu wirtschaften will der
bundeskanzler dennoch nicht aufgeben
putins brutale angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine seinen einsatz von energie als
waffe die rasant steigenden
energiepreise all das bestärkt uns nur
in diesem ziel wir müssen raus aus kohle
öl und gas ein ziel über das im grunde
einigkeit besteht nur der weg dahin ist
umstritten
wenn die entwickelte welt so
entschlossen ist dann könnten sie uns
die schulden erlassen das geld könnte
dann in grüne aktivitäten fließen und
der umwelt helfen
verheerende fluten wie hier in bohrungen
die 100 milliarden dollar jährlich haben
die industriestaaten ärmeren ländern im
kampf gegen den klimawandel versprochen
jetzt müsse das geld auch fließen
fordern experten glaube das ist sehr
wichtig vor allem für die länder des
globalen südens
dass sie merken es geht nicht nur um die
absichtserklärungen sondern die wirklich
wichtige währung zur zeit sind
glaubwürdige zusagen für glaubwürdige zu
sagen bleiben jetzt noch vier monate
zeit dann ist klimakonferenz in ägypten
es gibt noch viel zu besprechen
personen und güter auf die schiene das
ist der klimafreundliche königsweg in
sachen mobilität es wäre der königsweg
heute war die produktion im größten
europäischen bmw werk lahm gelegt die
fertigen autos konnten nicht
abtransportiert werden
oberleitungsschaden bei der bahn die zug
chefinnen und chefs können jetzt ein
extra seminar belegen empathische
ansagen im störfall für ihre passagiere
wird jede fahrt zum wagnis kleiner
auszug aus der vergangenen woche die
gefürchteten roten hinweise im db
navigator auf dem handy weichenstörung
störung im betriebsablauf
halt entfällt aktuelle verspätung
121 minuten
woran liegt das und was es zu tun hans
jürgen thiel
so zeigt sich die deutsche bahn gerne
taufe des hundertsten ic vier heute in
mainz auf den namen rheinland pfalz
zuwachs für eine stolze
hochgeschwindigkeitsflotte die aber
gerade auf hauptstrecken immer öfter
ausgebremst wird die pünktlichkeit im
fernverkehr ist mit 58 prozent auf einen
tiefstand gesunken was jeder zweite
intercity oder ece erreicht sein ziel
mit mehr als sechs minuten deutlich
verspätet haupt verspätung sgr und noch
nie wurde so viel im schienennetz gebaut
zeitweise auf über 850 baustellen pro
tag zerschlissene fahrwege bröckelnde
brücken was über jahre vernachlässigt
wurde um mehr rendite auszuweisen soll
jetzt in einem kraftakt fit für doppelt
so viele fahrgäste ab 2030 wagen geplant
und beauftragt von der db netz sparte
die offenbar mit der herkulesaufgabe an
grenzen stößt
die hat es leider bis jetzt nicht auf
die reihe gebracht die vielzahl an
notwendigen baustellen so zu
koordinieren dass nicht jede baustelle
eine eigene sperrung m zufolge hat denn
diese vielzahl an sperrungen durch
schlecht koordinierte baustellen führte
zu dass die kapazität im netz massiv
sinkt und das wiederum führt zu den
verspätungen die wir gerade haben
währenddessen versinkt der staatskonzern
immer tiefer in schulden und das obwohl
der netzausbau vom bund bezahlt wird mit
über 34 milliarden euro stärkt die
deutsche bahn so tief in den roten
zahlen wie noch nie in ihrer geschichte
es mangelt an effizienz sagen kritiker
was alle fachleute beklagen ist dass
innerhalb der db die prozesse zu
kompliziert sind man hat zu viele
verwaltungsleute die mitreden man hat
die arbeit in zu viele unterschiedliche
gesellschaften aufgeteilt die alle auch
gegeneinander kämpfen und das heißt man
hat also tatsächlich innerhalb der db an
strukturproblem und dass das sicherlich
zumindest ein teil der heutigen probleme
erklärt probleme die die bahn kundschaft
ausbaden muss der güterverkehr ist
massiv beeinträchtigt hunderte züge
können nicht losfahren weil das netz
überlastet es fahrgäste im
personenverkehr müssen mit verspätungen
und verpassten anschlüssen rechnen und
werden damit oft allein gelassen
es muss sehr viel mehr und sehr viel
besser informiert werden und man muss
vor allen dingen auch die dinge die in
der zukunft passieren könnten durchaus
mit einplanen und sagen liebe leute
fahrt vorsichtshalber dann lieber so das
klappt auf alle fälle und genau das
fehlt unpünktliche züge baustellen
koordinationsprobleme rekordschulden es
läuft nicht rund bei der db immerhin die
ic flotte wird zügig modernisiert bleibt
die c4 nummer 100 zu wünschen dass er
seine hochgeschwindigkeit trotz allem
auch wirklich aus fahren kann
hat lutz ist der bahnchef und jetzt bei
uns hallows guten abend schön dass sie
da sind und haben sie das ja viele ihrer
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im zug
die rollen mittlerweile nur noch genervt
mit den augen wenn wieder mal waggons
fehlen oder im ece das wasser ausfällt
und damit auch sämtliche toiletten
wie erleben sie denn ihre bahnfahrten
oder fahren sie vorsichtshalber nur noch
auto nein ich bin in den letzten wochen
in der tat ganz oft mit der bahn
gefahren und erlebe das was auch alle
anderen kundinnen und kunden erleben
dass mit qualität und zuverlässigkeit im
moment nicht alles stimmt sowie die
kunden und kundinnen sich das gewünscht
haben und zu recht erwarten dürfen und
was wir auch an uns selber an ansprüchen
formulieren das tut weh aber es ist die
situation im moment tatsächlich das tut
weh auch den bahnchef offensichtlich
woran liegt es denn dass man sich
schlicht nicht mehr darauf verlassen
kann dass man so ankommt wie man
eigentlich möchte also bezahlt hat ja
richtig also es liegt muss man negativ
abzugrenzen das liegt nicht daran dass
wir irgendeinen personalmangel haben es
liegt auch nicht daran dass wir nicht in
den letzten jahren gott sei dank in züge
investiert haben es liegt daran dass
immer mehr verkehr auf einer ohnehin
schon knappen infrastruktur die durch
baustellen zusätzlich eingeschränkt
werden unterwegs ist und dadurch
engpässe entstehen und staus und damit
auch verspätung das ist unser
eigentliches problem deshalb müssen wir
wenn wir das system von innen heraus
gesunden wollen an die infrastruktur und
von innen heraus die kapazität und
qualität aus der infrastruktur heraus
vorantreiben warum wurde über jahre oder
über jahrzehnte muss man ja sagen an der
infrastruktur so geschlagen und
vielleicht auch ganz an sie ganz
persönlich warum haben sie das mit sich
machen lassen
zur wahrheit gehört sicherlich und das
ist auch kein geheimnis unter den
experten das über jahre und jahrzehnte
die deutsche schieneninfrastruktur
unterdimensioniert noch unterfinanziert
war in den letzten jahren hat sich das
zum positiven hin jedenfalls deutlich
geändert aber der vorn und hinten ich
haben sie gerade selbst gesagt sie haben
ja massive probleme gerade mal jeder
zweite zug im fernverkehr ist noch
pünktlich und das heißt bei der bahn
sechs minuten ist auch noch in karenz
zeit schon eingerechnet warum was ist da
schiefgelaufen
wir haben nicht die infrastruktur die
wir brauchen für den verkehr um die
nachfrage für die wir ja dankbar sind
und deshalb müssen wir nach vorne
betrachtet eben die zusätzliche
kapazität schaffen wir haben eine
infrastruktur die über alter die ist
deshalb störanfällig und wir müssen aus
der infrastruktur heraus das system
jetzt gesunden mehr kapazität schaffen
bessere verfügbarkeit damit die
störanfälligkeit runter geht aber das
heißt auf deutsch es wird jetzt erst mal
noch schlimmer bevor es besser wird um
das bau- und kommen wir nicht drum herum
viele themen der letzten wochen haben ja
auch mit den baustellen zu tun deshalb
kann und müssen wir in den nächsten
wochen monaten und jahren weiter bauen
wir müssen das bauen aber effizienter
und effektiver organisieren ich glaube
da sind wir uns alle einig das was wir
vor einiger zeit waren und auch
bundesverkehrsminister wissing
vorgestellt haben dieses
hochleistungsnetz zeigt in die richtige
richtung dass wir das netz von einem
problemfall zu einem stabilitätsanker
entwickeln nutzen sie sagen man muss
baustellen bündeln die bauarbeiten
bündeln sie hauen mit der faust auf den
tisch das war bereits 2008 10 das machen
sie jetzt gerade wieder aber vor vier
jahren viereinhalb jahren haben sie das
auch schon gemacht in der ganzen zeit
hat sich offenbar nicht viel getan ist
das auch für sie so ein job bei dem sie
die ganze zeit gegen windmühlen an
kämpfen hingegen mit mühe an kämpfen
würde ja heißen dass es keine wirkung
zeigt ich glaube wir haben auch mit der
aktuellen bundesregierung jedenfalls
breites einvernehmen dass es ein weiter
so nicht geben darf und deshalb sind wir
ja dabei mit diesem aufbau des
hochleistungs netzes und gerade den hoch
belasteten korridoren die wir dann
general sanieren genau das aufzubauen
was wir brauchen ein hochleistungsnetz
was den namen verdient hat jetzt macht
der verkehrsminister habe mir gerade
schon kurz angesprochen volker wissing
der sagt er macht das jetzt zur
chefsache
das ist ja auch eine ansage an sie ganz
persönlich denn eigentlich sind sie ja
der der bahnchef was heißt das ganz
konkret ist das so die letzte
eskalationsstufe und jetzt muss dringend
schnell besserung her oder was nehmen
sie da davon mit von dieser ansage nein
das heißt ja nur das wunderbare person
art schicksalsgemeinschaft sind im guten
wie im schlechten und zur chefsache
erklären heißt dass wir jetzt gemeinsam
unsere kräfte bündeln und die energie
nach vorne treiben damit das entsteht
was wir brauchen eine infrastruktur die
vitte ist für wachstum verkehrs verlagen
und natürlich auch hier gute
betriebsqualität und pünktlichkeit für
unsere kundinnen und kunden und für das
klima ist die bahn ja auch wichtig sie
sollen bis 2030 ihre fahrgastzahlen
verdoppeln für das klima kriegen
allerdings die aktuellen fahrgastzahlen
ja schon nicht richtig gelebt haben sie
mal einen ausblick für uns wann spüren
die bahn kundinnen und kunden
tatsächlich besserung wann konkret wann
wird es soweit sein also wir haben uns
vorgenommen auch beginnend in den
nächsten wochen und monaten schon besser
zu werden wir werden einige baustellen
die ursprünglich mal für das zweite
halbjahr geplant waren jetzt bündeln in
baufenster die später stattfinden dass
es etwas was wir aktuell schon angehen
die werden die prävention in der
instandhaltung im netz deutlich um einen
dreistelligen millionenbetrag erhöhen
auch das gehen wir an also es findet
jetzt schon etwas stadt und in den
nächsten jahren muss ich das auch
verbessern im interesse und im sinne
auch der kundinnen und kunden sagt
richard lutz der bahnchef ganz
herzlichen dank dass ihr heute bei uns
war ja danke
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen um 19.30 aufgezeichnet
heute abend und jetzt hat gundula den
überblick über weitere wichtige
nachrichten heute die hitzewelle hat
auch deutschland erreicht höchstwerte an
rhein und mosel lagen heute noch bei 36
grad für morgen sagen die meteorologen
temperaturen von bis zu 40 grad im
westen voraus ärztepräsident reinhardt
forderte einen nationalen hitzeschutz
plan städte und kommunen müssten ältere
wolle und kinder in den einrichtungen
vor der hitze schützen
gewerkschaften forderten verkürzte
arbeitszeiten mehr pausen oder hitzefrei
für beschäftigte
die auch in südeuropa andauernde
hitzewelle erschwert vielerorts das
löschen der waldbrände in spanien wurden
heute 22 großfeuer gezählt in portugal
konnten die brände auf 5 halbiert werden
dagegen gelingt es in frankreich den
feuerwehren nicht die waldbrände an der
atlantikküste unter kontrolle zu bringen
in großbritannien gilt zum ersten mal
überhaupt eine extreme hitze warnung
einige schulen wurden geschlossen auf
mehreren bahnstrecken der zugverkehr
eingestellt viele krankenhäuser meldeten
die belastungsgrenze sei erreicht die
enorme hitze wie extrem wetter überhaupt
verursacht auch wirtschaftliche schäden
allein in deutschland kosten die folgen
des klimawandels
jährlich 6,6 milliarden euro das geht
aus einer studie hervor die das
bundeswirtschafts und klimaministerium
beauftragt hat stephanie beckert wie
werden denn die schäden im einzelnen
beziffert die studie zeigt vor allem
dass die kosten für extrem einzel
wetterereignisse in den vergangenen
jahren zugenommen haben und die aktuelle
hitzeperiode in südeuropa nur ein
vorgeschmack auf steigende folgekosten
sein könnte seit der jahrtausendwende
haben extremwetterlagen kosten von
mindestens 145 milliarden euro
verursacht gut 71 milliarden an schäden
entstanden durch starkregen und
überschwemmungen ein großteil davon geht
allein auf das konto der upload im
letzten jahr sturm hagel und schnee
schäden verursachten gut 32 milliarden
euro an kosten und auf fast 42
milliarden euro beliefen sich die
folgeschäden durch hitze und dürre
besonders betroffen davon die forst- und
landwirtschaft die alleine in den
hitzesommer in 2008 10 und 19 erhebliche
ertragseinbußen wegstecken musste auch
hitzebedingte produktionsausfälle in
industrie und gewerbe gehen in die
milliarden
zwischen wetterextremen und klimawandel
differenziert also in der studie heißt
es einen großteil der ermittelten
schäden gehe auf extrem wird der
ereignisse zurück für die der einfluss
des klimawandels klar belegt sei der
beruft man sich auf unter anderem auf
langzeitdaten aber was auch immer die
ursachen sind extremwetter ereignisse
haben zugenommen und es muss besser
vorgesorgt werden um die bevölkerung zu
schützen denn andere länder sind im
anpassungsprozess viel weiter als
deutschland etwa mit nationalen hitze
aktionsplänen oder dem grünen umbau von
städten und auch beim hochwasserschutz
vieles das sehen wir jetzt im flutgebiet
der könnte in deutschland schneller
gehen umso wichtiger verlässliche kosten
und schadensanalyse so lassen sich dann
auch dringende investitionen in diesem
bereich auch besser begründen die
rechnen sich und kommen auch am ende
billiger vielen dank stephanie für die
einordnung nach frankfurt zwei monate
nach dem schulmassaker von new value im
us-bundesstaat texas wirft ein
untersuchungsbericht der polizei
schweres versagen vor neue videos von
dem polizeieinsatz zeigen dass
zahlreiche einsatzkräfte im flur der
grundschule warteten
376 beamte seien an dem polizei einsatz
beteiligt gewesen hätten aber nicht
rechtzeitig eingegriffen der bericht des
texanischen repräsentantenhauses
beschreibt chaos fehlentscheidungen und
versäumnisse bei dem massaker waren 19
kinder und zwei lehrerinnen getötet
worden
die eu will die ukraine mit weiteren 500
millionen euro für die lieferung von
waffen und ausrüstung unterstützen
darüber sowie über neue sanktionen gegen
russland haben in brüssel die eu
außenminister beraten mit den neuen
finanzhilfen der eu außenbeauftragte
borel ankündigte erhöhen sich die eu
militärhilfen für die ukraine auf 2,5
milliarden euro nicht nur waffen und
schutzausrüstungen sollen finanziert
werden sondern auch treibstoff und
sanitätsmaterial
es brodelt in kiew und zwar hausgemacht
in der regierungszentrale von rodel mir
selensky der präsident hat gleich zwei
zentrale figuren des sicherheits und
strafverfolgungs apparats entmachtet
zwei persönliche vertraute noch dazu den
geheimdienstchef und die
generalstaatsanwältin
inkompetenz und verrat die vorwürfe die
im raum stehen wiegen schwer zumal in
einem land das kriegführen muss gegen
russische angreifer und sie stellen
drängende fragen auch an den präsidenten
selbst und seine entscheidungen ulrike
riddler
es geht um viel für den ukrainischen
präsidenten in diesen tagen es geht so
formulierte selensky um das fundament
nationaler sicherheit hochverrat gestern
dann der paukenschlag die lenski
suspendiert zwei seiner wichtigsten
beamten
bis heute wurden 651 strafverfahren
wegen hochverrats von mitarbeitern der
staatsanwaltschaften und
ermittlungsbehörden registriert 60
geheimdienstagenten sind im besetzten
gebiet geblieben und arbeiten gegen
unseren staat
der eine ivan bogdanov geheimdienstchef
und freund aus kindheitstagen enger
vertrauter und ehemaliger
wahlkampfleiter von sie lenski bakalov
soll enge verbindungen zum früheren chef
des geheimdienstes auf der krim gehabt
haben dieser war bereits am wochenende
wegen hochverrats verhaftet worden die
andere irina winnetou war
generalstaatsanwälten in ihrer behörde
sollen sensible informationen an
russische separatisten weitergegeben
worden seien auch heißt es seien einige
ihrer mitarbeiter zu den russen
übergelaufen
venedig war galt als populär sie leitete
die ermittlungen über die
kriegsverbrechen butscher
die suspendierung der beiden
behördenchefs kommt für sie lenski zu
einem denkbar schlechten zeitpunkt sein
land steht vor einer großoffensive oder
auch russland hat seit dem wochenende
seine angriffe verstärkt
russland hat stand sonntagabend etwa
3000 raketen gegen die ukraine
abgefeuert es ist unmöglich alle
angriffe zu zählen die sie gegen die
ukraine und gegen das ukrainische volk
gerichtet haben aber was ich versprechen
kann ist dass wir kriegsverbrechen zur
anklage bringen und kollaborateure zur
verantwortung ziehen
es ist neben all den gräueltaten in
diesem krieg keine atempause zu erwarten
nicht für den präsidenten und schon gar
nicht für das ukrainische volk
ja der präsident lässt also die spitzen
des geheimdienstes und der
generalstaatsanwaltschaft absetzen und
untersuchen dara hassanzadeh ist für uns
live in rackith in der ukraine sarah
guten abend wie kommt denn das bei den
menschen eines landes im krieg an
wenn man darf nicht vergessen dass die
menschen hier vor allem gerade am anfang
des krieges wochenlang vor ihren
eingängen von miet von mit blöcken von
die von ihren wohnvierteln wache
geschoben haben sie haben deswegen
wachen geschoben weil es ja unheimlich
viele eingeschleuste agenten gab davor
hat bei präsidenten mehrfach gewarnt und
diese menschen haben jetzt erfahren dass
kollaborateure mitten in den ministerien
sitzen und dass die leiter dieser
behörden nicht in der lage waren überall
die zeit die jetzt vergangen ist diese
ausfindig zu machen dass boost die
menschen das macht sie fassungslos und
das ist das große gesprächsthema hier
die bbc interpretierte das ganze jetzt
als eingeständnis dass die zahl der
überläufer erschreckend hoch sei kann es
also sein dass das ganze nur die spitze
des eisbergs ist
es kann schon sein wenn man sich
vergegenwärtigt dass der russische
geheimdienst im endeffekt 20 jahre zeit
hatte diese agenten oder doppelagenten
zu aktivieren zu rekrutieren und auch
immer weiter zu bezahlen so dass viele
in der ministerium vielleicht auch
gerade auf der mittleren ebene doppelte
gehälter haben kassiert haben es kommt
auch dazu dass die der verkehr soll
diese stadt ist im gegensatz zu allen
anderen städten nicht so heftig umkämpft
gewesen sondern ist relativ kampflos in
die russischen hände hält die hände
gefallen und die schulden der
bevölkerung liegt der verdacht nahe dass
dort auch kollaboriert wurde und diese
stadt und dieses gebiet ist ja jetzt das
hauptziel der neuen offensive von daher
werden sich die
doppelagenten nenne ich sie mal jetzt
schon gedanken machen ob es nicht genau
der letzte moment ist auf die andere
seite zu wechseln
jetzt wo salewski offensichtlich ganz
klare kante zeigen will in diesem fall
spannender analyse eine weitere front in
der ukraine dara hassanzadeh war das ein
live aus traf mit möglichst wenig licht
aus sicherheitsgründen daher herzlichen
dank und wir bleiben beim thema beim
thema krieg und die folgen die immer
weitere kreise ziehen und noch mal zu
grunde lagen auf der suche nach
alternativen zu russischen gas will die
eu die gasimporte aus aserbaidschan
deutlich erhöhen in baku unterzeichnete
eu-kommissionspräsident in von der leyen
eine entsprechende absichtserklärung
demnach sollen die gasimporte aus dem
kaukasus land bis 2027 auf 20 milliarden
kubikmeter pro jahr verdoppelt werden
wegen der drosselung der russischen
erdgaslieferungen kommt deutschlands
größter energieversorger juniper in
immer größere finanzielle probleme heute
musste der konzern seine
kreditmöglichkeiten bei der staatlichen
förderbank kfw über zwei milliarden euro
vollständig in anspruch nehmen und
beantragte weitere mittel derzeit laufen
verhandlungen mit der bundesregierung
über ein umfangreiches rettungspaket
zum interims geschäftsführer der
documenta in kassel ist der
kulturmanager alexander fahrenholz
ernannt worden schon ab morgen soll er
die künstlerische leitung übernehmen und
auch die aufarbeitung des antisemitismus
skandals vorbereiten aufgrund dessen
generaldirektorin schormann am
freitagabend zurückgetreten waren
der pop art künstler claes oldenburg ist
im alter von 93 jahren in new york
gestorben
der gebürtige schwede gehörte neben andy
warhol zu den bedeutendsten vertretern
des genres so schuf er zum beispiel die
fast zwölf meter hohe skulptur einer
krawatte die in frankfurt am main vor
der dz bank steht als künstlerische
auseinandersetzung mit dem dort üblichen
dresscode auch andere kunstwerke von
glas oldenburg wie die löffel brücke mit
krische in minneapolis sorgten weltweit
für aufsehen
hier wurde napoleon zum kaiser gekrönt
von hier aus wird jede entfernung in
frankreich gemessen sie ist das
meistbesuchte historische bauwerk
europas ein symbol für das kulturelle
erbe der westlichen welt viel mehr geht
nicht und dann steht sie plötzlich in
flammen
fünfzehnter april 2009 10 notre dame
brennt ein inferno
das kennen wir soweit aus den
nachrichten was sich im hintergrund
abspielt können wir jetzt im kino und
bei diversen streaming diensten sehen
vacano als regisseur von der name der
rose erfahren darin brennende
kirchenbauten auf die leinwand zu
bringen er hat minute für minute des
echten notre dame feuers recherchiert
und er ist dabei auf so unfassbare
pannen und versäumnisse gestoßen dass
sie klingen wie gemacht fürs kino aber
alles ist 100 prozentig war schwört der
unserer filmkritikerin sabine scholz
skurril haarsträubend dramatisch er habe
rein gar nichts dazu erfinden müssen in
wirklichkeit die fantasie überholt
[Musik]
paris im frühjahr 2009 10 notre dame
wird aufwendig saniert
wahrzeichen nationalheiligtum das
gedächtnis der geschichte frankreichs
am 15 april tritt ein neuer wachmann
seinen dienst an
das ist einer der brandmelder nie aus
den augen
die touristenströme fließen trotz der
laufenden sanierungsarbeiten
um 18 17 wird feueralarm ausgelöst
teuer dass du
doch der brandherd wird am falschen ort
gesucht ein irrtum mit fatalen folgen
während die messe fortgesetzt wird gehen
handy fotos mit rauchschwaden bereits um
die welt die feuerwehr erfährt davon
zuletzt und nur auf umwegen
ist
die notrufzentrale weiß bislang von
nichts das kann eine fotomontage sein
wird aber verdammt echt aus
unglaublich was regisseur jacques anouma
an pannen und absurden mit geschickten
recherchiert und für seinen spielfilm
rekonstruiert hat tut liga tasdorf ich
glaube alle katastrophen entstehen aus
einer verkettung von kleinen störfällen
fehlern und versäumnissen und da noch
das pariser chaos jeder macht was er
will jeder park bauer will die feuerwehr
konnte nirgends durch das ist paris das
ist frankreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
inzwischen droht notre dame bereits
einzustürzen als die feuerwehr eintrifft
ist der brand weit fortgeschritten anno
inszeniert die dramatische
rettungsaktion wie einen hollywood
action thriller
wenn wir mit unseren leuten darauf
kommen können wir es schaffen meine
leute und ich melden uns freiwillig
es gibt keine verstärkung
ich habe mit allen feuerwehrleuten
gesprochen die damals im einsatz waren
meist junge leute die alles riskiert
haben sie sagten ihr leben sei weniger
bedeutsam als die historischen steine
von notre dame das letztlich niemand
ernsthaft verletzt wurde ist unglaublich
viel pathos große emotionen in madrid am
in flammen ist ein ungewöhnlicher mix
aus realismus und heldenepos
mal kurios mal spannend
und vor allem mit spektakulären kino
bildern
[Musik]
motto damen steht noch ist nicht
eingestürzt und wird wieder aufgebaut
bis 2024 das ist zumindest der plan
und damit entlasten wir sie in dieser
sommernacht
christopher wehrmann meldet sich um
23.40 mit unserem heute-journal update
und von uns allen hier im heute schon
mal thiemann sie einen angenehmen abend
tschüss
[Musik]
beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die klimakrise lässt grüßen mit
der erhitzung des planeten nehmen die
hitzetage zu im trend und einige zu tage
stehen uns bevor sehen hier in rot
dargestellt temperaturen über 30 grad
und diese wetterlage wurde ja schon seit
einigen tagen vorhergesagt und diese
hitze die wandert von spanien über
frankreich nach deutschlands oder
erreicht dann am mittwoch den osten
deutschlands erwarten durchaus werte bis
40 grad morgen schauen wir erst in die
nacht da ist wenig los die sterne
funkeln wettermäßig kaum was los und
schon morgen am tatverlauf so ähnlich
die sonne scheint von meist einen blauen
himmel aber die temperaturen steigen
massiv dann aber die nacht ist
interessant 10 grad im norden hier
nochmal ordentlich kühl genauso im
südosten das ist noch mal die
gelegenheit die wohnung ordentlich
auszukühlen denn die hitze im westen die
erreicht werte bis 40 grad es kann
örtlich auch darüber gehen temperaturen
an der ostsee jesus am kühlsten bei 25
grad und übermorgen verlagert sich die
hitze dann in den osten jeder
temperaturen von 38 bis 40 grad und dann
wird auch schwül nämlich im westen gibt
es dann am mittwoch schauer und gewitter
das wird ziemlich unerträglich im osten
ist die trockene hitze noch da bis 40
grad ja und danach ist es nicht mehr
ganz so heiß und damit ein schöner abend